c'est moi ou on entend des cris de singe
quand bob kampusch balle touche le
ballon et en effet c'est bel et bien
dressés à nos joueurs et en particulier
envers paul pogba et ousmane dembélé
regardez la vidéo cette fin de saison
avec le chocolat d'espagnol est pas
encore tout à fait gagné et avec la
ligue des champions et pogba
continue cette séquence a pris
énormément d'ampleur sur twitter la fifa
devra annuler la coupe du monde là bas
c'est une honte ce n'est pas l'esprit de
cette compétition et tant pis pour le
manque à gagner des cris de singe
ridicule en provenance des fans de la
russie qu'en pogba touche la balle
c'est une honte même la ministre des
sports et ancien grande championne
d'escrimé laura flessel a tenu à réagir
son son compte le racisme n'a pas sa
place sur les terrains de football
nous devons agir de concert au niveau
européen et international afin de faire
cesser ces comportements inadmissibles
voilà les russes se voulait se veulent
rassurants ils ont mis un tweet
franchement bien sûr qu'on n'aime pas
mais les quais le truc qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
et est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
annuler du monde aux richesses que ses
produits et services dans les schistes
quand il faut pas annulée il faut pas
globaliser non plus tous les russes ne
sont pas racistes
moi je suis allé souvent la barre oui à
des problèmes dans les stades n'y a pas
qu'en russie qu'avec problème ne réside
à d'autres l'hymen est allé aussi
exactement ils mènent des actions très
forte contre les hooligans et contre ça
mais il ya encore des individus qui sont
racistes et qu'il exprime dans les
stades mais poutine est en train de
lutter contre ça j'ai bon espoir que ce
soit alors la question la russie qui
organise la coupe du monde j'aime ou
j'aime pas fait moins la vérité vous
n'aimez pas ah non mais moi je déteste
ya pas que ça comment voulez vous qu'ils
respectent les joueurs étrangers de
quelques couleurs qui soit quand on voit
les expropriations convenu pour
construire tout en russie il ya aucun
respect de rien donc pondu construction
de vous j'ai choisi la russie pour
organiser la coupe du monde ça vous
dérange moi je suis content ça garde la
chine mais le racisme et s'arrêtent pas
aux frontières russes n'importe quoi
donc s'emparer de s'emparer de ce qui
s'est passé iric évidemment condamnable
pour faire une polémique autour de la
coupe du monde et la russie ne doit pas
organiser la coupe du monde c'est
complètement débile
mario balotelli ce que je sais moi
parlez jamais une expropriation en
france comme il y en a toujours qui
jouant les gars y et cris de singe quand
il jouait en italie il s'est plaint des
cris de singe à bastia s'est plaint des
cris de singe à dijon c'est le foot dans
sa globalité qui doit épargner un vrai
dilemme
alors voilà russie s'avoue pas tres la
coupe du monde en russie vous aimez non
enfin c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé
hier c'était absolument inadmissible
c'est que c'est vrai que ça n'existe pas
quand on réussit ça existent aussi
ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est un
problème global c'est pas le problème de
la russie ce problème d'un certain
nombre de supporteurs d'idiots qui sont
c'est cela qu'il faut qu'il faut [ __ ]
dehors mais bon après un très beau la
russie elle est ce qu'elle est mais je
crois qu'il faut pas faut pas mettre
pays dehors comme ça enfin il vaut mieux
parler avec lui vaut mieux aller dans ce
pays vaut mieux essayer d'avoir des
liens avec lui plutôt que de le mettre
en dehors du jeu m'a jamais moi c'est
pas contre le peuple russe c'est contre
le le gouvernement russe qui a quand
même eu comme trichet dopage d'état et
globalement je trouve que c'est
effectivement ça ne plaît pas forcément
fin que le monde soit en russie on va
regarder ce qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs combat on va pas
interroger tout le monde surtout essuyé
ne sommes pas là x 112 pour ces fous